three two one action we love all your
awesome scenes in descendants three mal
the fight scenes and the dragon scenes
are awesome but we know you had some
help we know that there is another mile
on set who helps you with all those
tricky scenes and with that purple wig
we can't even tell the difference we're
here to show your stunt double some love
stunt doubles are responsible for some
of the most hectic scenes on the Disney
Channel while it's a given that they
need to resemble the actors they play
some of the resemblances are uncanny
check out these 10 Disney Channel stunt
doubles who look like they're actors
dove Cameron and Liv and Maddie before
she was the most rotten kid on the Isle
Doug Cameron starred and Liv and Maddie
she played both Liv and Maddie which
posed some challenges sports during her
time on the show deaf became close to
her stunt double this picture shows the
two of them in the makeup chair they
look so much alike there's no way we
would be able to tell them apart on the
small screen Selena Gomez and Wizards of
Waverly Place we loved Wizards of
Waverly Place we miss Alex and the rest
of the family some of those magic scenes
were wild that's where the stunt doubles
come in here is Selena with her stunt
double we're pretty sure the devil is
wearing a wig but otherwise these two
looked pretty similar they have similar
noses and eyes the resemblance is
uncanny
Laramie doc Shaw in pair of kings
wouldn't you love to be the king or
queen of your own Island
we sure would that's why we loved pair
of kings King boomer was one of our
favorite characters ever he was played
by Laramie doc Shaw but in the last
couple of years of the show he needed a
stunt double
that's where Samuel J Paul comes in it
can be hard to find stunt doubles for
kids because of the dangerous nature of
the job the stunt double looks like an
older version of doc the thing that is
the most similar between the two is
their smile
minions please move the throne debby
ryan and Jesse we all remember the
episode when Jesse got our first big
break as a stunt double she played the
double for an Australian actress in the
show but did you know that there were a
few times Debbie Ryan needed her own
stunt double in at least 15 episodes
Debbie stunt double was Katy ashen now
these two don't look exactly alike at
first but those cheeks are really
similar and do they have similar shaped
eyes with a red wig it totally worked
[Music]
Miley Cyrus and Hannah Montana
Hannah sometimes when you're a stunt
double you get the best of both worlds
you get to film fun scenes on set and
you don't have to deal with all the
stress of being a celebrity and this
photo we get to see Miley Cyrus and her
stunt double on set Miley is posing with
the help of her son double this done
actors need to see how the stars move
and act so they can do the same then
they get to do the scary stuff Raven
Symone in That's So Raven we're going
way back in time for this first one it
seems like Raven was always getting into
tricky situations on that So Raven and
for some of those situations
she needed a stunt double one of her
doubles was Natasha Hopkins and we can
totally see it
subtract about 15 years and these two
had to look similar their facial
features make them look like they are
related zendaya
and shake it up we just loved all the
dancing and drama from shake it up the
star has executed most of their dance
scenes but occasionally a stunt double
was needed for a scene soon daya how
stunt double for at least one episode
this is Tameka Brownlee and we can
absolutely see some resemblance just
look at the facial expression she makes
she and zendaya could be sisters to
someone why can't it be us Sophia Carson
in descendants to evey might be a
fashionista but she still knows how to
fight and defend herself
Sophia Carson did some awesome fighting
singing and dancing and dissonance - but
the movie wouldn't have been the same
without her stunt double Allyson
brunette she is the perfect double for
Sophia and look how cute they are
together
Allyson was so awesome in descendants -
that she returned to double for Sophia
again in the third movie they don't call
her evil for nothing Brenda's song we
never get tired of The Suite Life of
Zack and Cody and we just loved london
tipton she sometimes got herself into
hilarious situations so brinda song
needed a stunt double her double was
played by Jade Kwan we can see the
resemblance here's a fun fact Jade is a
super successful stunt actor she's been
in transformers and The Hunger Games
she's moved on from her Disney Channel
days dove Cameron in descendants three
we're ending this video with another
deaf Kamran entry it's hard work being
the daughter of Maleficent and Hades Mao
needed body doubles for all three
descendants movies from fight scenes to
riding the moped a lot of scenes are
really dangerous for the second and
third films her body double was Louise
koretski we loved the pictures of them
together they looked like they could be
sisters for you first and that's a wrap
but before you go tell us which actors
stunt-double duo's you thought looked
the most alike sound off in the comments
section thanks for watching give us a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things we'll catch you
later
[Music]